[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue c'est l'heure
de parlement hebdo on va refaire toute
la semaine politique et parlementaire
bonjour katia bonjean michael et cette
semaine avec nous françois de rugy
bonjour bonjour comme gisèle
loire-atlantique et soutien d' emmanuel
macron on va revenir avec vous sur le
fait de la semaine françois fillon qui a
donc été mise en examen
une première sous la vème république
benoît hamon qui a dévoilé les
évolutions de son programme 198
proposition au total et puis et puis
emmanuel macron en visite à berlin voit
là pour aller voir un gars merkel et on
va commencer par ce début de semaine
marquée par la mise en examen de
françois fillon mise en examen pour
françois fillon avec 24 heures d'avancé
une semaine encore marquée par les
affaires on voit tout cela avec nathalie
goyer avec 24 heures d'avancé
françois fillon est mise en examen face
aux juges le candidat de la droite n'a
pas souhaité répondre aux questions dans
le bureau des magistrats il a fait le
choix de lire une longue déclaration
avant de se voir notifier ces trois
chefs d'accusation détournement de fonds
publics complicité et recel complicité
recel d'abus de biens sociaux et enfin
mise en examen pour manquement aux
obligations de déclaration à la haute
autorité
face à cette situation le candidat de la
droite persiste et signe il maintient sa
candidature
je suis innocent que ma femme a
travaillé avec moi pendant des années
comme c'est le cas de centaines et de
centaines de parlementaires dans le
passé est en ce moment même
et je suis convaincu que la justice même
si ça prendra du temps
établir à cette innocence dans le camp
de françois fillon
cette mise en examen est un événement ça
ne change rien tout ça est une histoire
annoncé depuis la saisine du but du pn
est foncée et la transmission juge
d'instruction on le savait dès le début
qui aura une mise en examen donc change
absolument rien maintenant en avant et
on continue la campagne c'est ça qui est
important
françois fillon et est calme serein et
déterminé comme on l'est tous il a
confiance dans la justice de notre pays
et nous avons confiance dans françois
fillon donc une mise en examen ça n'a
absolument pas une condamnation contre
ça va lui permettre d'avoir accès au
dossier de pouvoir mieux se défendre et
vous verrez qu'à la fin et bien sa
vérité la vérité éclatera et sera
reconnu par par la justice de son côté
la gauche réclame le retrait de françois
fillon
il me semble que non seulement on doit
tenir ses engagements il avait annoncé
qu'il ne serait pas candidat s'il était
mis en examen mais donné tous les gages
d'honnêteté et de probité
cette situation est inédite c'est la
première fois qu'un candidat à
l'élection présidentielle est mise en
examen au sein de régies le parquet
national financier maintenant on va se
saisir de l'enquète autour de la sphère
des costumes
c'est la goutte d'eau mais disons que ça
fait beaucoup
parce que françois fillon il doit faire
face à des mises en cause depuis
maintenant plus de deux mois et qui
porte sur tout un tas d'affaires qui ont
un point commun c'est la question de
l'argent et de l'argent à son profit
personnel au profit de sa famille ça
d'avoir été moi je tiens à rappeler
la sphère françois fillon consultant
cette société de consultants qui l'a
créé quand il n'était plus premier
ministre et qui n'était pas encore
redevenu député ses terres qu'il a
utilisé d'ailleurs une faille de la loi
qui fait qu'on ne peut pas créer une
société de consultants de ce type quand
on est député
mais quand on peut continuer à avoir une
activité qu'on a commencé à voir enfin
là il avait commencé quelques semaines
avant réalité ne l'avait pas commencer
elle avait juste déposé les statuts de
sa société cette société n'est toujours
pas capable de dire de façon claire
nette précise quelles sont ses clients
les sommes en face de chaque client et
le travail fourni
parce que de toute façon est ce qu'il ya
eu un travail fourni et puis c'est
pareil pour les mises en cause
concernant les emplois d'assistants
parlementaires pour sa femme et pour ses
influences couvrent leurs gains pour ses
costumes
c'est la même chose à chaque fois et moi
je pense que il faut pas considérer
qu'une mise en examen est une
condamnation ça c'est clair corps permet
en revanche c'est lui qui a dramatisé à
plusieurs reprises la situation je le
rappelle est la question que je pose ce
même pas de savoir s'il peut être
candidat ça ça j'allais dire ça le
regarde ça regarde sa famille politique
il a pris des engagements qu'il ne tient
pas mais le peu que 6,1 sur fuck
c'est ce qu'il est qualifié avec tous
ces problèmes avec la mise en cause de
la police et de la justice qui l'a fait
à plusieurs reprises est-ce qu'il est
qualifié pour être présent et réputé
l'honnêteté c'est une valeur centrale
pour vous dans cette dans cette campagne
d'ailleurs ça s'applique à tous les
vents l'honnêteté s'applique à donner de
la transparence la capacité à fournir
des explications à assumer ce que l'on a
fait et à fournir des explications je
constate et le petit passage convient de
revoir le montre qui date de seulement
deux jours que monsieur fillon n'est pas
capable de donner d'explications sur la
réalité du travail fourni par sa femme
payer comme si ce matin le mans terre or
ça fait des semaines et des semaines que
ça dure moi je peux vous dire que toutes
les personnes qui ont travaillé pour moi
à un moment ou un autre comme assistant
ou assistante parlementaire
on peut
facilement de leur fournir les preuves
de leur travail au sein de régies tout à
l'heure vous parlez d'un camp d'été
approchent de l'argent savait que ces
descentes des thèses qui seront repris
par le front national n'ont pas je n'y
passe à jeudi candidat qui a
manifestement des problèmes avec
l'argent c'est à dire tout simplement
d'ailleurs qui manifestement a un niveau
de vie supérieur à son niveau de revenus
est à dire que ses revenus de députés ou
ses revenus de ministre où ses revenus
de premier ministre ne lui suffisent pas
manifestement pour son train de vie pour
qu'ils cherchent à toute force c'est ça
moi que je vois comme fil rouge
bon à la limite moi vous savez quand on
achète un costume à 5 ou 6000 euros mois
celui là il doit valoir 300 euros mais
ça me peu m'importe
chacun ses goûts après tout bon mais le
problème c'est que il faut l'assumer
avec ses propres revenus surtout quand
on veut être assumer les plus hautes
fonctions de la république française
parce que sinon les françaises ont
l'impression de quoi c'est que peut-être
ils vont élire quelqu'un qui en fait à
des liens de dépendance avec soit des
entreprises soit dge dessin généreux
donateurs et ça ça pose un problème
ap ap au par rapport à l'exercice de
cette haute fonction la plus haute
fonction de la république française qui
est la présidence que vous dites qu là
ça peut s'appliquer aux autres candidats
est ce que tous les candidats sont au
dessus de tout soupçon est bien sûr
s'avança vous voulez faire la
transparence avait une élection
présidentielle une campagne
présidentielle on passe les candidats un
peu au scanner d'un point de vue
politique d'un point de vue personnel
c'est ce qu'ont choisi un projet et là
on parle plus beaucoup des projets avec
et c'est bien problématique mais y
compris des projets françois fillon
françois fillon et des positions très
tranchées sur un centre de sujets qui du
coup sont escamotés par tous les
commentaires sur ces affaires monsieur
fillon et le candidat vous avez vu qui
est le csa le conseil supérieur de
l'audiovisuel l'a confirmé qui a eu le
plus de médiatisation
mais c'est pas pour parler
malheureusement des projets alors malgré
ce sont bruyants des affaires et bien
chacun poursuit sa route et notamment à
gauche avec chacun son projet et ses
idées
et cette semaine benoît hamon a donc
présenté son programme en somme 98
points le candidat socialiste qui a
puisé son inspiration de divers côtés l
amont d'un gaza avant de dérouler son
programme benoît hamon tacle ses
adversaires
cette campagne est polluée par l'argent
l'argent pour ce qui concerne un certain
nombre de candidats comme la présence
dans les projets de certains candidats
de l' influence des forces de l'argent
et c'est à mes yeux la signification
aussi de cette crise d'une crise où
manifestement aujourd'hui ce qui inspire
les responsables politiques repose moins
sur l'intérêt général que sur une somme
d'intérêts particuliers que l'on veut
satisfaire et qui trouve toujours une
jolie place au chaud dans les programmes
électoraux des uns et des autres puis il
revient sur ses fondamentaux notamment
le revenu universel
enfin plus précisément sa mise en place
il permettra dans sa première étape dès
le 1er janvier 2018 d'augmenter
automatiquement leurs revenus des actifs
ouvriers employés indépendant étudiants
dont les revenus sont inférieurs à 2200
euros nets prioritairement donc ceux
dont les moyens sont les plus faibles
près de 19 millions de français seront
concernés benoît hamon entend également
réserver 50 % de la commande publique
aux petites et moyennes entreprises
mesure chère à arnaud montebourg il se
veut aussi le défenseur des services
publics très frappant de voir combien la
fermeture d'un cabinet médical
la fermeture d'un bureau de poste
sympath immédiatement dans le résultat
des élections qui suivent dans un
territoire par l'augmentation du vote
front national
la meilleure manière de lutter contre le
front national ça ne pas de déréguler
notre économie c'est de maintenir un
haut niveau de service public
benoît hamon propose 1 49 3 citoyens
c'est à dire la possibilité pour 1 % du
corps électoral d'être à l'initiative
d'une loi ou d'un référendum
enfin dans les autres mesures de son
programme la reconnaissance du vote
blanc
le droit de vote aux étrangers pour les
élections locales et la légalisation du
cannabis pour les majeurs est-ce que ce
programme dont
repréciser est assez rassembleur est ce
que il peut convaincre certains qui
hésitent à gauche à rejoindre le
candidat socialiste d'adhérer à ce
projet je ne crois pas parce que c'est
un programme qui manifestement est un
peu une motion de synthèse du parti
socialiste est encore d'une partie du
parti socialiste
on voit bien que ça a été fait bon c'est
surtout le programme de la primaire de
benoît hamon
et puis il ya une petite touche de
montebourg une petite touche de peillon
une petite touche que duflot a mais en
revanche je crois pas que manuel valls y
ait contribué
je ne crois pas que sylvia pinel même si
elles étaient présentes il y ait
contribué en tout cas je ne retrouve pas
du tout les thématiques sont plus
annuels valser vous êtes surpris
on voit bien que c'est moi ce que
j'avais appelé la gauche rouge verte
quoi c'est à dire voyez bien cette
gauche qui a été toujours dans la
contestation toujours en la protestation
qui ne se préoccupe pas beaucoup de
l'exercice des responsabilités parce que
sinon vous ne faites pas une proposition
comme ce revenu de base qui a changé
plusieurs fois là il est universel mais
il ne touche menu tout le monde ce qui
est un peu bizarre pour quelque chose
d'universel
enfin il coûte quand même 35 milliards
dans la version avant c'était 45 dans la
version encore avant c'était 400 mhz et
35 milliards on les trouve et où les 35
milliards
moi je sais comment ça se finisse à ces
les classes moyennes qui vont payer
d'ailleurs bizarrement il a dit que
c'étaient les actifs alors les petites
retraites
elles sont pas concernés pour le coup
c'était un des points de son précédent
projet qui pouvaient être entendus mais
le ce que eu des carrières discontinues
et qui ont travaillé à temps partiel etc
qui arrivent à la retraite avec une
petite retraite
bon donc moi je vois bien que c'est
facile de programme pas fait pour
exercer les responsabilités qu'il n'est
pas fait pour relever les défis de
demain d'ailleurs il revendique c'est
libre à lui mais une forme de gauche de
l'utopie bon peut-être qu'il ya des
électeurs qui ont envie d'un petit
moment d'utopie pendant quelques mois de
campagne électorale
mais là on décide de l'avenir de la
france de ce qu'on va faire pour la
france pendant cinq ans sur l'économie
où sont les propositions qui vont
permettre de développer l'activité
économique en france de renforcer et de
développer nos entreprises rien et sur
l'écologie parce que l'art l'art
visiblement mme cécile duflot elle dit
je me suis senti comme chez moi c'était
un candidat écolo rester avec sont des
perturbateurs endocriniens taxe carbone
fin du diesel 50% d'énergies
renouvelables dans le mix énergétique je
l'avais pas dit autre chose pendant la
prime
cécile duflot avait dit qu'elle était
très ému par le discours de françois
hollande lors de la première conférence
environnementale qu'elle aurait eu l
impression qu elle aurait pu l'écrire
bon mais justement
justement pourquoi je rappelle cette
petite anecdote si on n'est que dans le
discours
si on n'est que dans l'idéal opposition
il ya le monde idéal sans nucléaire sans
diesel sans perturbateurs endocriniens
tout le monde
moi je pourrais signer vous vous
pourriez sans doute signer vos frères
vos soeurs vos parents vos enfants parce
que le monde rêve d'un monde idéal comme
ça mais la question en matière
d'écologie
comme en matière d'économie c'est
comment on y arrive quel est le mode
d'emploi
quels sont les états vous êtes plus de 4
sur les objectifs à cinq ans d'ici là
annuel macron sur l'écologie mais je dis
que y compris sur l'écologie même si
emmanuel macron c'est quelqu'un qui
s'est intéressé qui a pris en compte ces
enjeux peut-être plus récemment benoît
hamon la paix également à l'occasion de
cette campagne temps et bien eux c'est
avec des objectifs concrets avec des
dispositifs par exemple quand on parle
de la pollution de l'air est con il faut
réduire la pollution de l'air à la
source donc réduire le nombre de
véhicules polluants en circulation vers
nous nous proposons avec emmanuel macron
une prime à l'achat non seulement
véhicules neufs propre véhicule hybride
ou hybrid electric electric mais aussi
des véhicules d'occasion parce que vous
commencez à avoir un marché de
l'occasion sur l'électrique sur
l'hybride est solide électrique et ça
c'est beaucoup plus pragmatique un croc
des gens comme écolo oui il est plus
pragmatique et plus pragmatique au
programme à l'écologie comme en matière
d'économie et c'est important d'être
pragmatique et je crois qu'il ya
beaucoup de français qui ont envie d'une
politique pragmatique plutôt de grands
discours qui en général
si jamais on arrive aux responsabilités
on revient six mois après devant les
français le lundi 20 n'ont finalement
c'est un peu plus compliqué donc bah
finalement on abandonne
moi j'ai pas envie que demain si on
arrive aux responsabilités on abandonne
au contraire j'ai envie qu'on transforme
sans parler donc des manuels macro qui a
reçu cette semaine encore quelques
soutiens et de son côté manuel valls lui
a décidé de ne pas parrainer benoît
hamon c'est est ce que ça veut dire pour
autant qu'il soutiendra emmanuel macron
ça seul l'avenir le dira en tout cas les
amendes à gabat nous résume cette
semaine pas de soutien à benoît hamon
mais pas encore de ralliement emmanuel
macron c'est la position que semble
adopter manuel valls
hier il a réuni ses soutiens l'assemblée
nal eller a déclaré je ne parierai
personne et je n'ai aucune leçon de
responsabilité ou de loyauté à recevoir
l'ancien premier ministre qui est
dénoncé le sectarisme de benoît hamon
est proposé la création d'une plateforme
des progressistes pour lutter contre le
front national
pour l'heure un soutien à emmanuel
macron n'est pas prévu même s'il n'est
pas exclu
ce n'est pas ça le sujet mais nous
regarderons à l'aune de ce qui pourrait
se passer dans les semaines qui viennent
du risque d'un 2e tour front national
droite pourquoi ce que nous ferons ce
que l'on constate aujourd'hui qu'il a
déjà beaucoup de nos amis de concitoyens
de de gens de gauche qui ont fait le
choix de soutenir
emmanuel macron une réalité au même
moment sur le plateau de tf1 le candidat
à l'élection présidentielle ne cache pas
son amertume côté moi je ne me sens pas
trahi mais sans doute les électeurs de
la primaire se sont ils aujourd'hui
trahis en démocratie le respect de la
parole donnée c'est important en
démocratie le respect de l'issue du
scrutin
c'est important sinon comment lutter
efficacement contre toutes celles et
ceux qui mettent en cause la démocratie
comment lutter efficacement contre le
front national
quand justement soi même on ne respecte
pas le verdict des urnes alors manuel
valls appellera-t-il a voté manuel
macron avant le premier tour
en tout cas l'ancien premier ministre
est d'ores et déjà prévenu l'accueil ne
sera pas très chaleureux
je nie pas fonder une maison d'hôtes
c'est fait pardon de vous le dire nous
avons créé un mouvement politique je
suis candidat à la présidence de la
république
la candidature à la présidence de la
république ces rapports entre un homme
un projet un peuple c'est cela faut pas
se tromper on n'est pas encore aux
législatives
à titre personnel se sont déjà plusieurs
proches de manuel valls qui ont rejoint
emmanuel macron parle notamment de
manuel valls et il faudrait qu'ils
choisissent manuel valls qu'il choisit
son camp aujourd'hui il l'a déjà fait un
premier choix c'est de ne pas parrainer
benoît hamon ça a du sens quand même ça
veut dire qu'il ne se reconnaît pas qui
n'a pas envie
par cet acte
que nous avons nous les parlementaires
les mères c'est de pouvoir parrainer un
candidat en déposant notre formulaire au
conseil constitutionnel décide de ne pas
le faire parce qu'il sent bien il ne se
reconnaît pas dans un projet de benoît
hamon après - manuel valls et je pense
qu'il est suffisamment grand pour faire
les bons choix sans que moi je lui donne
des conseils ou qui que ce soit d'autre
d'ailleurs ce que je pense c'est qu'il
ya un choix de cohérence politique
vous savez bien on nous oppose à nous et
responsables politiques notamment
nous avons été candidat manuel valls moi
même à la primaire la règle la règle la
règle la règle mais la règle ne règle
pas un problème politique de fond et on
le connaissait avant la rivière le
problème politique et doit quitter le
parti socialiste aujourd'hui pour vous
rejoindre
en tout cas je crois que manuel valls c
est ce qui était à sa réunion qui sont
pour beaucoup des députés des sénateurs
je pense qu'ils réfléchissent un choix à
faire qui est un choix de recomposition
politique autour de projets politiques
qui sont assez différents le projet d'
emmanuel macron le projet de benoît
hamon
benoît hamon il enclenche aussi une
recomposition politique à la gauche la
gauche ce que j'appelais la gauche
rouges verts
cette gauche plus contestataire et il
veut peut-être emmené le parti
socialiste verseaula peut-être
d'ailleurs qu'il veut le transfert est
peut-être qu'il veut le faire changer
non
et de l'autre côté emmanuel macron a
aussi enclencher une recomposition
politique mais quand même le fait que
certains hésitent comme manuel valls
mais aussi jean yves le drian actuel
ministre de la défense est ce que
finalement c'est pas vous dit tant mieux
pour emmanuel macron que certains
attendent ce qu'il a tant besoin
non je soutiens en revanche qui est
clair maintenant ces essais admis par
tout le monde c'est emmanuel macron
n'est pas dans une logique de
négociation ni d'appareil ni de groupe
car il va pas dire je négocie avec
manuel valls pour manuel valls et ses
amis où je négocie avec tel ou tel et
soutien serait vraiment bienvenu
notamment celui du ministre de la
défense semble on rassemble et il vaut
mieux d'ailleurs quand on est candidat à
l'élection présidentielle avoir à gérer
de nouveaux soutiens tous les jours que
de nouvelles défections tous les jours
ce qui est quand même le cas des deux
candidats issus de ce qui était je le
mets au passé les deux principaux partis
politiques de la vie française
c'est-à-dire les républicains et le
parti socialiste emmanuel macron qui
était justement lui à berlin pour
rencontrer angela merkel qu'il a été
accueillie apparemment com
de dette il dit avoir de nombreuses
convergences avec la chance de lire
qu'il a reçu plus d'une heure écoutez sa
réaction à la sortie de l'entretien
en aucun cas un adoubement vous savez
dans une campagne présidentielle
française
le sun la douve manque existe c'est
celui du peuple et je vous ai souhaité
bonne chance
je ne vais pas faire parler la
chancelière nous sommes vie finalement
emmanuel macron c'est un bon candidat
pour un gala merkel il a des engagements
sur la dette publique sur la
consolidation budgétaire
je crois qu'en hongrie merkel comme
d'autres dirigeants européens sont
inquiets et évidemment de savoir ce que
donnera le résultat des élections
françaises hexion présidentielle
législatives parce que si jamais c'était
marine le pen qui devenait présidente
voyez bien que ça aurait des
conséquences pas simplement sur la
france mais aussi sur l'union européenne
on a vu en landes d'ailleurs aux
pays-bas que finalement n'y avait pas de
fatalité à ce que cette extrême droite
nationaliste populiste raciste xénophobe
gagne les élections il ya eu un coup
d'arrêt en hollande je pense qu'il y
aura un coup d'arrêt en france et c'est
emmanuel macron qui peut donner ce coup
d'arrêt à la montée du front national
n'est pas et surtout redonner espoir à
la france est aussi alors là aussi le
jeune a trois filles - comme m eur oui
bien sûr mais ce que je note c'est que
emmanuel macron il est reconnu d'ores et
déjà comme un interlocuteur par la
première ministre britannique theresa
may par la chétive derrag mentir un gala
merkel mais aussi par yannis varoufakis
qui est l'ancien ministre des finances
grec et qui est plutôt à la gauche de la
gauche on voyait qu'il est reconnu comme
un interlocuteur
et ça c'est important parce que dans le
choix des français de la représentation
de la france à l'étranger aussi des
critiques écouter françois fillon
monsieur macron c'est la gauche
hollandaise relooké c'est le radeau de
sauvetage des naufragés du quinquennat
vous avez aimé les synthèses molles de
hollande
vous allez adorer les cinq les
élastiques d'emmanuel macron le même
jour monsieur macron recevait le soutien
d'alain madelin et celui de robert hue
c'est vrai que quand on regarde de
robert hue alain madelin vous sentez
résidents on a faim on savait que ces
formules on pourrait aussi dire que
françois fillon c'est le nicolas sarkozy
relooker un vous savez c'est à dire
trans verbal parce que vous avez vu ces
meetings maintenant parce qu'à une forme
de radicalisation de françois fillon
contre la justice contre les
institutions il en appelle au peuple de
droite contre son propre parti contre
ces élus enfin c'est quand même une
dérive assez hallucinant pour quelqu'un
qui prétend être président de la
république
donc moi je crois que françois fillon il
ferait mieux de défendre son projet
plutôt que de passer tout son temps
parce qu'on a bien compris qu'il allait
passer tout son temps les disqualifier
bon point commun d'ailleurs avec benoît
hamon s'est passé tout son temps à taper
sur emmanuel macron je crois que pour
l'avenir de la france que chacun
présente son projet et que chacun puisse
voir la crédibilité des projets des uns
et des autres en matière économique il
est dangereux de le redire sur social
d'écologie et c'est qu'il est dangereux
pour l'avenir de la france
je crois que françois fillon aujourd'hui
si jamais il était élu président de la
république on aurait une forme de
régression régression économique et
sociale parce que son projet est un
projet de régression dans plein de
domaines sur les retraites sur la santé
sur la protection sociale sur l'écologie
on n'en parle jamais mais lui il a écrit
des choses en matière d'écologie
suppression du principe de précaution de
la constitution retour des ogm retour
des gaz de schiste abrogation de l
histoire est par ailleurs françois
fillon s'est aussi sur la politique
internationale
on n'en parle plus de ses positions sur
la russie qui sont extrêmement dangereux
car la france est pour l'heure justement
toutes ses positions font que certains
changent de côté à l'image du sénateur
de l'yonne apparentés lr jean-baptiste
lemoyne écouter ce qu'il a dit ce matin
sur notre antenne
ce qui est important c'est le la
crédibilité de la parole politique et
moi justement quand j'ai vu que il renié
cette parole j'ai décidé de reprendre ma
liberté
et effectivement je me suis tourné vers
une mode macro parce que je voulais pas
me résoudre à un vote blanc je lance un
appel aux électeurs de la droite et du
centre en leur disant n'ayez pas peur
vous y réfléchissez et bien fait que moi
le 23 avril glissé un bulletin de vote
emmanuel macron mêmes rejoignez nous
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce soutien
venu de la droite
je crois que c'est à l'image il a raison
de le dire de ce que font un certain
nombre d'électeurs et des tris de droite
sert que la recomposition politique dont
je parlais tout à l'heure elle passe par
cette idée qu'il y à des hommes et des
femmes politiques de des responsables
des élus mais aussi de simples citoyens
et les
militant qui travaillent ensemble à ce
qu' ils voient bien que les vieilles
querelles de chapelles de partis moi
j'en ai trop souffert je peux vous dire
à l'assemblée quand j'étais dans
l'opposition ou quand je suis dans la
majorité depuis cinq ans de voir que
sous prédit qu'une proposition vient de
la droite alors quand on est de gauche
on doit être content d vice versa alors
on parle de tout ça avec le partenaire
du figaro bonjour jean ferrat c'est
bonjour françois de rugy vous l'avez dit
tout à l'heure vous ne soutenez pas
benoît hamon tout comme manuel valls on
l'a vu la question l éclair à quoi ça
sert de faire des primaires si personne
ne soutient le vainqueur si la primaire
elle a servi à ce que les citoyennes et
citoyens de gauche qui ont participé a
quand même eu deux millions deuxième
tour face un choix et on savait bien
qu'à gauche peut-être plus qu'à droite
d'ailleurs
il y avait des options très différentes
et à un moment donné il faut trancher
pendant le quinquennat de françois
hollande ça bien été le problème c'est
que souvent on n'a pas tranché
et donc on a essayé de faire croire que
tout en menant une politique plutôt pro
entreprise on pourrait garder dans sa
majorité des gens qui sont viscéralement
et de façon pavlovienne contre les
entreprises comme monsieur hamon comme
monsieur montebourg et c est bien là la
primaire elle a permis d'avoir le débat
et ça a été tranchée donc moi je ne je
conseille à benoît hamon facto comme
verdict et non mais benoît mais attendez
c'est pas pour ça en revanche que ça
construit automatiquement un
rassemblement parce qu'à un moment donné
c'est pas parce qu'un processus que vous
régler un problème politique de fond que
l'on connaissait avant seulement la
différence avec avant et notamment avec
cinq ans dix ans c'est qu'aujourd'hui il
ya une offre politique alternative
crédible alors le parti socialiste n'a
jamais eu ça en face de lui c'est pour
ça qu'il est beaucoup de socialistes
sont très fébriles ils sont un peu
énervés et qu'il tape sur emmanuel
macron d'une façon d'ailleurs est monté
en faisant toutes leurs allusions par
rapport au front national il va falloir
que ça cesse aussi ça parce que c'est
indigne d'un débat politique pour
l'élection présidentielle
il ya un autre que tant qu'il se prépare
c'est celui des législatives jean paul
delevoye qui en charge des investitures
chez en marche a annoncé cette semaine
que finalement les uns sur pourrait être
annoncée seulement du second tour ce qui
n'était pas là ce qui avait été annoncé
plus tôt est-ce que c'est justement un
moyen de tenir en haleine les soutiens
et de pouvoir ajuster les choses
jusqu'au dernier moment il ya une
réalité en marche c'est un mouvement
neuf un mouvement jeune emmanuel macron
il a souhaité il a bien fait que pour
les élections législatives ce soit un
processus ouvert donc ça crée beaucoup
évidemment de vocation de personnes qui
ont déposé leur candidature il ya plus
de 10000 pour 577 circonscriptions il ya
un gros travail qui est fait sous
l'égide de jean paul delevoye justement
qui est un homme d'expérience à la
commission d'investiture pour évidemment
passer au tamis toutes ces candidatures
c'est un travail long moi je souhaite
d'ailleurs jeu on en a parlé avec
emmanuel macron que l'on fasse peut-être
les choses par plusieurs étapes s'est
amusé pas obligés d'investir d'un seul
coup 577 candidats et donc d'ici le
deuxième tour de l'élection
présidentielle c'est tout à fait ce soit
ouvrir la voie à des accords électoraux
dans l'entre-deux tours par exemple avec
des partis partenaires le ps on il
pourrait du coup rejoindre emmanuel
macron d'entre deux tours et négocier
des places au juste latino mais nous ne
sommes pas dans la logique d'un accord
mais faire un autre nom mais après ça on
en met le parti socialiste puisque vous
poser la question si on devait passer un
accord c'est avec qui conte le pass
c'est avec benoît hamon candidat du
parti socialiste à l'élection
présidentielle admettons admettons c'est
une hypothèse d'école qu'ils soient
éliminés dès le soir du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle et qu'il
appelle à voter pour emmanuel macron je
sais pas s'il le fera un pour l'instant
il n'a rien dit au deuxième tour est-ce
que c'est avec lui et sur sa ligne
politique
est-ce que c'est avec jean christophe
cambadélis chef du parti socialiste
est-ce que c'est avec manuel valls qui
parle d'une maison des progressistes ou
en tout cas peut-être d'un nouvel espace
politique qui en dedans en dehors du
parti socialiste donc niveau mieux le
porte un nom mais il vaut mieux que les
personnes qui veulent être candidate aux
initiatives y compris des députés
sortants et sortantes
eh bien ils fassent leur choix de
carrière moi je n'imagine pas tellement
des députés qui pendant toute la
campagne présidentielle disent ben moi
je ne choisis pas mais je veux quand
même me présenter aux législatives
ensuite vous même et je sollicite la
confiance des français sans même leur
dire que je batte à l'élection mais vous
même vous souhaitez être candidat ou
celle être candidat rhissa tifrit je
l'avais déjà dit à la presse en marche
c'est déjà entériné du coup pour vous
les investitures ne sont pas fait
d'accord je suis logé à la même enseigne
dans votre circonscription
oui ça oui parce que les gens qui disent
vous fait ça pour avoir une seule
conception banon je suis élu depuis dix
ans j'ai fait est élu dans cette
circonscription deux fois et je n'ai pas
fait des accords justement comme
d'autres pour me faire parachuter dans
un endroit où j'aurais apprécié de
chance alors cette semaine on a aussi
entendu jean pierre mignard qui est un
avocat proche de françois hollande qui
soutient emmanuel macron et qui a dit
que françois hollande allait avoir un
rôle dans la future majorité des manuels
macro si jamais il était à vous fait
sourire il a été démentie par le
porte-parole du mouvement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé non mais ça
est bien dans une interview vous pouvez
enlever une phrase jean pierre mignard
s'est pas le porte-parole d' emmanuel
macron c'est pas le porte-parole de
marche et c'est pas un professionnel de
la politique vous pouvez sortir une
phrase la découpe et dire ça qu'est-ce
que nous imaginer qu est ce que ça veut
dire ça veut rien dire un choix bien
loin ça monsieur fillon il adore ça
attention si vous vous démarquez vous
allez avoir londres enfin arrêtez vous
savez très bien que si emmanuel macron
est élu président de la république
ce sera une alternance et pour faire
autre chose que ce qui a été fait
pendant cinq ans justement ce qu'a
emmanuel macron il fait partie comme moi
de gens qui ont tiré les leçons du
quinquennat de ce qui n'avait pas marché
il a démissionné du gouvernement tout
survol pour hollande et j'ai hollande
est un ancien concept majorettes eric
non vous n'allez pas non un ancien
président de la république sous françois
hollande à partir du 8 mai il sera
ancien président de la république
vous n'allez pas par une nouvelle
majorité dans un nouveau gouvernement
sera le passé merci beaucoup merci
s'interroger dans un était notre invité
à des visites de programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires et bonne semaine
[Musique]